you
[Music]
look at this meeting I'm an applied
statistician working at a university my
primary goal is helping my collaborators
make sense of their data through
secondarily is to try to develop new
statistical methods to better make sense
of their data sort of thirdly to to
implement those methods in software
we're for nearly 20 years I've been
working on in our package called our QTL
and I want to tell you about that
experience so that
the the idea for this package came from
a friend of mine visited and we were
talking about the need for specialized
software in sort of the applications
that we worked in and it was actually
the week that our version one came out
in in the year in January of 2000 he
wanted to write it in MATLAB and I
wanted to write it as an r package and I
was five years younger and devoted more
time to it so it became an r package and
you know this figure shows lines of code
over time each dot is one cran release
so it was first on cran at the end of
2001 it's grown to be nearly 40,000
lines of our code and 25,000 lines of C
code and new you know over 15,000 lines
of the dot Rd documentation which you
know back in the day we typed by hand
that this didn't actually and it you
know for the first seven years it was
without version control the way that I
kept track of versions is by tying up
the file at its current state and just
saving that you know tar.gz file I
didn't get into version control until
2008 so it was somewhat the I mean that
well and that that will so you'll see
what my experience has been I guess but
I feel like I should tell you a little
bit about the package and so in doing so
I really need to tell you a little bit
about the science so I studied genetics
or complex traits in mozi and mice mice
have a big advantage for genetics and
that you can make inbred lines so if you
take a pair of mice and make them and
then do repeating repeated mating
between siblings for 20 generations or
200 generations so what
you get at the end is a strain of mice
that are all genetically identical and
that if you can figure out which one's a
male and which one's a female across
them the offspring will all be
genetically identical again the
advantage for genetics really is
simplifying a lot of things and being
able to make really large crosses work
our interest in the genetics of in mice
is really focused on understanding the
genetics of human disease we're not
trying to cure disease in mice we're
trying to have a better understanding of
the underlying biology of human disease
the basic experiment that's done it
would be an inner cross where you take
two strains of mice that differ in some
trait like one strain of one strain has
high blood pressure
the other strain has low blood pressure
you're trying to find what genes are
contributing to that difference in blood
pressure so you do a cross that's
identical to what Mendel did with his
Peas
to mix up the mix up the high blood
pressure chromosomes and the low blood
pressure chromosomes and then what
you're gonna do is is measure you know
get a bunch of offspring measure blood
pressure and all those mice which really
for that phenotype would be the hardest
part of this study measured the blood
pressure of all those offspring and
measured genotype along each chromosome
whether a mouse is blue blue pink pink
or blue pink at a given position and
then we're gonna scan across the genome
and look for regions of the genome where
there's an association between what
genotype you have whether you were blue
blue blue pink or pink pink whether
that's associated with the outcome blood
pressure so the results of this sort of
analysis is you know a plot across the
mouse genome um you know on each
chromosome the curves that for a test
statistic that's indicating when when
this thing is high you are saying
there's evidence for an association but
genotype at that location and blood
pressure those Peaks we call QTL or
quantitative trait loci a region of the
genome that is affecting a quantitative
trait blood pressure but effectively
what you do is at every position in the
genome you do an analysis of variants to
see is there a difference in the average
tray across the three genotypes and
that's you know the goal of my package
are QTL it's called QTL because we call
these these sites we're looking for QTL
or the genetic loci that affect this
quantitative trait it does a bunch of
other things but yeah going back to the
package and I just want to talk a little
bit about you know the the state of it
in my experience with it twenty years
into a project there may be some good
things about it
but they start to become harder to
identify some of the ark some of the
code in this package is really good and
I'm proud of it some aspects of the are
of the interface the user interface what
you know the code that the user types to
get something to happen I think was a a
good idea that I had back in 2000 2001
it includes a lot of data Diagnostics
features and and data visualization and
and it's quite comprehensive you know I
had this idea that I would implement all
methods good and bad so that you would
have sort of one place that you could
try things out and understand them and
it's quite flexible that you know I can
implement new ideas about you know for
analyzing data with this other people
could potentially do so as well you know
but
it's more easy to it's easier for me to
think about the bad things the first
example I want to give is just about
data getting data into r4 this kind of
cross so these sort of data I mean I
need for this sort of experiment I need
a set of traits I need a set in and then
genotype data of are you blue blue blue
pink pink pink at sites along the genome
and then I no need to know where those
positions are in the genome and the the
main input format we use is just a comma
delimited format where the first few
columns are all phenotypes and the
traits and then the remaining columns
are all positions in the genome and
their genotypes and the first row has
for those later columns with the markers
the the sites in them in the genome it
has their chromosome ID in the second
the third row has their position and
that the first thing I do reading this
in is I need to split the trait data
from the genotype data which I do by
looking for you know where it's the
first non blank cell in that what it
sort of as our QTL was used sort of
people started to load in data with lots
of traits like say 25,000 traits and
they would ask me like why is it taking
so long to load the data and I would say
how many trick am i how much data do you
have and they'd say 25,000 phenotypes
and I'd say it's gonna take a while it's
a big data set but then I had a
collaboration where I had data that was
you know 20,000 traits and it took you
know it was like 20,000 phenotypes and
then the usual kind of markers and maybe
300 mice and it took a minute to load
this CSV file into our and I was like
this something's wrong
it shouldn't take a minute to load a
file that's really not very big so so I
looked into the code and which I declare
to be the stupidest code ever the this
code is trying to find the first
non-blank cell in that sort of second
row it does that say but it does that
fry looping from one to n where n is the
number of columns and at you know it
first says is the first cell blank is
the second cell black are the first two
cells blank are all three the first
cells blank or the first four cells
blank but the first five cells are blank
when it when that fails and it breaks
out of that loop and then it does a bit
of extra work of like trying to find
that what it well so in loading my data
with 25,000 columns of traits that took
about a minute it was about 58 seconds
was spent on this for loop and two
seconds was actually the loading the
data and everything else so I I like to
say and I open source means everyone can
see my stupid mistakes and and version
control means everyone can see every
stupid mistake I've ever made so that
that's not the only bad that code is no
longer in the package it you can find it
in version control it's on github but
there is other bad code that's in the
package there one of the function one of
the are functions that does sort of a
major thing of a two-dimensional scan of
the genome to try to look for a pair of
these QTL is 1,400 lines long which is
not mean the function is 1,400 lines
long in the c code i mentioned that that
this package has almost 25,000 lines of
C code almost 20 percent of that is
related to this one sort of thing that
I'm trying to do
I mean it's complicated but it's also
complicated and not really you know it I
mean yeah it's not what I would do today
the the package I the I'm really happy
with it the interface for the users I'm
less happy with maybe the data
structures that I set up in the year
2000 there's some really pretty baroque
data structures to put it nicely this is
a bit of code that I actually do type
because it's something that I want to do
cuz and so there's some stuff that you
want that's kind of deep inside some
really complicated object there are lots
of inconsistencies of the code and like
you have functions that are doing kind
of similar things that have names that
don't like they're not designed then
they're not designed and they have
arguments that are really the same
argument but that the two different
functions have different name
for that argument you know a marker
might be marker or it might be M name
one who say that the maybe the biggest
mistake I've made it has been really
useless warning messages a lot of my a
lot of users of our QTL this is their
first experience with are their first
experience with software other than
Excel and and web browsers maybe ring
word so they get a warning message X
prime axis singular that I mean what are
they supposed to do with that what does
that mean to them and so a lot of the
questions I get are I get this warning
message X prime axis singular what
should I do
and I think that I was looking at
looking at this yesterday I think X
prime axe you know I know what that
means but I would that could be a
picture of something really to someone
that doesn't it doesn't know the details
of linear regression X prime axis
singular I mean X prime at I mean
parsing that sentence is is difficult
tests tests there's a there's just not
very many tests
I actually said this I don't need tests
I have users Jani Brian has said if you
use software that lacks automated tests
you are the tests and that it brings me
some comfort that we agree the Hadley
his his paper about unit testing and and
the the tests that package it's not that
we don't test our code it's that we
don't store our tests so they can be
rerun automatically and that this to me
is just like the essence of Hadley I
mean this is exactly why I love Hadley
because he starts it off by saying you
know it's not that we don't test our
code so it's not that we're like
terrible people just we have room for
improvement so yeah but how did this
happen how did I spend 20 minute 20 20
years trying to you know develop and
maintain and support a package that has
these problems you know I didn't know
any better at in I didn't know any
better at the time I mean I started to
know better but by then it was like too
late it seemed like there was not enough
rewriting done because I mean I have the
to-do list I have it to do listen here
that's just absurd I had I mean I just
like none of that stuff I'm never gonna
do so going back and redoing stuff that
I've already done just seems like I mean
it works I don't have any tests that
would prove it but I did test fit
there's not enough planning I was you
know I mean personal weaknesses there
are trade-offs to make that I made that
maybe I made the wrong choices a couple
of other quickly things that I've
learned making are QTL that for you know
when you're writing documentation
for a package what users care about is
tailored examples you know example you
know it show me your package in action
doing exactly what I want to do so I
could like plug in my data at the top
and run it do just what you did and so
if you're gonna put effort into
documentation it's really think about
how people are gonna use it and focus on
that first kind of a ute general user
guide sort of second examples within the
detailed documentation third formal
documentation it seems like it's
important but no one mean seems to read
it user support I put a lot of effort
into answering people's questions I get
emails a couple times a week at least
still and and I think if you want people
to continue to use your your software
you really need to help them to get
started and so I mean and and so on I
really want to make myself useful if if
they need help getting their data into
unto our QTL I'm happy to have them send
me the data and I'll figure out what's
going on and send em code and the their
data back or fixed code I mean fixed
data that works going back to QTL
mapping so that the main target is to
try to find a gene so it's sort of
isolate a position in the chromosome
where the gene that's affecting this
trait is sitting and the those regions
are too big so sort of modern
experiments of this kind are really
focused on trying to break down the
chromosome smaller by doing more
generations and sort of mix together
more than two strains and neither of
these really works it can be studied
effectively with the current package and
so and also the the size of data sets
have increased enormous ly so I've been
focusing on RQ gl2 now as a minecraft
plugin
that basically starting over completely
to try to be able to handle high
dimensional data to be able to handle
these multiple strain modern crosses and
I'm trying to avoid making the mistakes
that I made the first time around our
CCP our CPP R oxygen to unit tests with
tests that have been just make
everything work better my life is so
much nicer now but I still have some
personal failings
so our QTL - is not like not without its
flaws but you know finally I mean I've
devoted a lot of my time to software
even though sort of the people that
evaluate my work don't really care about
it at all because like they just care
about grant money and citations of
aiming papers but it has actually been
really helpful for my own scientific
work to find new collaborators and it
just you know statisticians RP job
should be to make ourself useful and
this has really been I've sort of the
way in which I've been most useful I
think a lot of people involved in it and
you know I'm a bit Li squatter if you
want to see these slides they're at our
Studio 2019 at bitly thanks very much
[Applause]
[Music]